oh the thought that I had sitting here
well well next made that point was that
I think when you this course is going to
be not replicated but it will go on in
many many parts of the world in many
schools I think it'd be a great idea if
it began with you in person if possible
or otherwise through the magic of video
giving this the lecture you just gave
which i think is a really good way of
structuring and purposing a seminar like
this one another maybe other seminars
that don't fit that template but I would
urge you to do that I mean goodness I
the idea that we can say how how we're
going to impact you with this course
it's interesting fact I've taught now
easily a hundred courses at Yale and
that's a question I've never been asked
and stuff maybe it is oh it's certainly
the point certainly is not some sort of
technical expertise it is some kind of
cosmopolitan knowledge of the role of
faith in the very complex history that
you're going to be part of and some of
you will be not just part of it but
influential parts of it and it seems
quite likely that the humanizing spirit
and I may be humanizing I guess is
tendentious in this context but I'll use
it anyway the humanizing spirit that is
that pervades this seminar is a pretty
good starting place for dealing with
difference and the thing I forget if
it's point three or point for but
getting from from grudging tolerance to
mutual respect is no easy task in many
of the world's arenas and it I would say
if you carry that ambition
and cultivate the skills that by itself
would be a worthwhile purpose for this
course you know III suppose I suppose I
want to answer this in the way that sort
of what makes me tick in this course if
I ask my question myself this why do I
think this is really important why am I
so excited about this what does that do
to to me and maybe you can pick out
something for this for yourself or maybe
not right that may be but the debt
that's probably the way in which I want
to answer it and if you ask me why am i
passionate about this course i think i
would say because i want to bring the
idea of purpose of the ends of human
life individual life institutional life
organizational life to bear upon the
functioning of our very complex world
I'm really interested what what really
drives me is concept of human
flourishing in the context of a global
common good and in the world which is
interconnected interdependent different
faiths with different visions of human
flourishing different visions of the
comal global common good living together
side by side and if we can learn how not
to give up on asking the notion of
purpose asking the question of purpose
and pursuing human flourishing that's
broader than just my own interest but at
the same time learn how to live together
in in a way that is mutually enriching
what a world we would create I so if I
ask myself why am I engaged in this
that's why I'm engagement I want to roll
up my sleeves make a better world with
people of different faiths living
together while not giving up my notion
of human flourishing derived from a
venerable faith tradition and respecting
others who have other variable
traditions as well so I'm hoping that
you will go away with a vision
human flourishing with some kind of
instruments to how to work toward
realizing that vision and working
together alongside with others tour that
same goal and for me I think it's very
it's very simple i'd like you to better
take out from this why this is such an
important question I think this simple
as that that it is really important but
secondly and leading on from both Doug
and Miroslav I hope because this is the
very best thing about a university you
probably went well maybe Fred knows it
because he's been out of them on the
world come back and so on but most
important thing I think is to be able
always to gain fresh insight into the
world and if what this has done has made
you think about maybe your own faith and
maybe your own faith in its place in the
world and how it relates to other people
then that's I think something that's
really worth while but i think that the
single most important thing you can get
out of this is to understand that with
out a knowledge of this issue and a
belief then that is a result of your
knowledge it's important to act if
that's what you if that's what you can
get out of it that's that's this is good